>>Ankur Kotwal: Welcome everyone to the Android
Developer Lab.
This is the first episode of the Android Developer
Lab plus.
And we're really excited to be launching it.
So this is a revamp of what we used to have
called Office Hours, and it just basically
expands on that show.
So let me start off by introducing the team.
>>Anirudh Dewani: I will first here.
Hi guys, I'm Anirudh Dewani and I'm based
out of the Hyderabad office in India.
>>Tony Chan: I'm Tony Chan and I am based
out of Hong Kong.
>>Ankur Kotwal: And I'm Ankur Kotwal and I'm
based out of Sydney, Australia.
So, we're really glad to have everyone joining
us today.
We are just getting the show started, so just
give us a few minutes.
We are just making sure that people online
are able to join our link.
And as soon as we've got that up, we should
be right to go.
So in the meanwhile, Tony do you want to give
us an update on some of the questions we had
last week to do with low level media?
>>Tony Chan: Yes, sure.
So let me pull the question up.
So basically there are two questions we got,
we left unanswered last week.
So we're trying to find the answer, here you
go.
So the first one is "Can the [indistinct]
StageFright classes be used in the JNI code
somehow?
JNI versus Android source tree incompatibility
and stable native interface."
So basically the answer is yeah, why not.
And you can certainly do that but one thing
you need to pay attention is for, if you are
using the native interface there is no guarantee
those interface will not change.
So when you go for that approach make sure
you pay attention to our source tree changes
and make sure that it's not broken.
So that's the caveat.
So another question we left unanswered last
week was "Is there any supported way to stream
live video and audio?"
So I think last week we forgot to mention
something.
We do have http live stream support in Honeycomb
and plus devices, so also prior to Honeycomb
there are some public commercial solution
as well for live streaming and we have seen
developer done that, written their own solution
before on our end before.
So it's pretty doable.
So I guess that’s pretty much addressed
by some of the unanswered question last week.
>> Ankur Kotwal: Thanks Tony.
So what we're going to do today is a little
bit different.
As I mentioned the format is changing.
So let's get started, we're going to flick
over to our presentation right now.
And here we go.
So, first thing we'll just start off with
some news.
These are just basically some of the events
that have happened in terms of the Android
developer world over the last week.
The first one is that we've launched preview
2 of the Android Developer Tools version 21.
So this the upcoming version.
Don't be too concerned if the, you are unable
to get the URL down or not, we’ll go and
edit the YouTube video and put it in there.
But certainly you can do a Google search for
this.
The next one is that we, one of our team members
has put in, has released some sample code
actually for some scrolling tricks.
So let me just bring that up.
So the ADT preview is up, Tor Norbye is one
of the engineers that works on the SDK tools
and he's announced the availability of these
tools on his Plus page.
Roman Nurik and Nick Butcher who are also
Android Developer Advocates, put together
this great little sample app.
There's some code there and you can just see
what it basically looks like.
You'll notice that there are some scrolling
tricks that we've been implementing with our
apps.
So as they scroll down here you'll notice
that the little white bar disappears.
But as soon as they pull down, the white bar
shows up again.
So it's kind of like a floating or docked
bar across the top, but there's a sticky version
of it as well.
So, it's a really nice source code there so
you can see if it's worth implementing or
something that you consider to be useful for
your apps.
We use it in the Google play client actually.
Another one is what we call the pinhole progress.
So it's something that we sort of introduced
in the Google movies client and you'll notice
as your, as well as books actually.
So as you're downloading content you get this
little pin which is what you toggle to say
whether it downloaded or not.
And the progress bar starts to fill up.
So Roman, again, put together some great sample
code and you can go and grab it from the URL
that's just displayed here as well.
It’s just a shortened version.
Or you can just follow Roman on Google Plus.
So with that being said that's pretty much
the biggest things that have happened from
our side of the Android Developer ecosystem.
I know there's been plenty of things in the
community side.
The other thing we're going to do today that's
a bit different is that we're going to have
a message from our sponsor.
And our sponsor this week is the Android Manifest
File.
So we thought we'd share some pro-tips with
you guys because there has been some confusion
in the past and ways to really optimize your
development.
So we thought we'd share those with you.
We’re gonna start off by talking about uses
SDK.
So uses SDK is a tag that you'd have in your
manifest file and there's a couple attributes
on there that are quite important.
And they can really make some dramatic impacts
to you apps compatibility and availability
on Google Play.
So let's get started.
The first one is the minimum SDK version or
we state it as min SDK Version.
So what it is, it basically tells the device
that this app needs a minimum version of this
API level to be able to run.
Now when you specify the minimum SDK version
in your manifest file, it is up to you as
the developer to ensure that you're not calling
APIs that are not supported in that SDK version.
Or if you are, you're putting version gates
around them so you're checking that that particular
API is available on that version of the platform.
Now the good thing is that once you start
using the SDK version, if you're using a more
recent version of the Android developer tools
we added lint support.
So lint is a compile time check, that goes
and sees if you're doing anything not quite
right with your source code.
This is an example where what it'll do, it'll
actually check what the minimum SDK version
that has been specified in your manifest is
and to see whether you're calling any particular
APIs that are not supported in that minimum
SDK version.
So it's a really nice handy tool and those
warnings should definitely be actioned.
The thing about the minimum SDK version is
that when a user goes to install an APK, so
let's say you're side loading an app, the
operating system will actually check whether
it is a version that’s higher than, or greater
than or equal to the minimum SDK version.
So the operating system itself will confirm
that.
Google Play also does this, so if there's,
if you're running on let's say a Gingerbread
device and a minimum SDK has been set to Honeycomb,
if you search for that app on Google Play
on your Gingerbread device, Play won't actually
show that app.
Actually if you go to the web version of Google
Play, when you sign in, you search for that
particular app, you'll notice that when you
try to install the app through the web version
there's a way you can choose which device
you want it to install to, it won't actually
present devices that are below that minimum
SDK version.
So by default the value that’s' there, it's
an implicit value that defaults to 1, which
mean it supports every version of Android,
but we always in terms of best practices,
we recommend that you explicitly specify the
minimum SDK version.
And it's also a way for you to make sure that
you're targeting the right set of users.
If you have a very media heavy app for example,
or an app that, you know, requires a certain
level of device, minimum SDK is one way to
do it.
One way to check, to ensure that it doesn't
get installed on the wrong device.
So, please, you know, go in and explicitly
specify minimum SDK.
You might be looking at that and saying, well
it's not there by default so why do I need
it?
Well, the next bit of useful information is
the target SDK.
The target SDK is basically saying to , well
you're saying by specifying a target SDK that
this particular app is guaranteed to run on
a particular API level.
And the reason that you should be stating
it is that it actually enables a whole bunch
of features in the background.
So what we recommend, and we're going to talk
about what some of those features are, what
recommend in terms of our best practices is
that you should always set your target SDK
version in your app to be latest version of
Android.
OK?
Just because you set it to, let's say 15,
API level 15, if you try to install it on,
let's say a Gingerbread device which is API
level 9, it's not going to actually prevent
it from running.
What it will do is that it will default back
to the API level 9 behavior on those API level
9 devices.
And this is where minimum SDK helps, because
what you do is you use the minimum SDK to
specify what's the lowest version or oldest
version of Android that you can run and you
use target SDK to specify the one that you're
really targeting.
Now remember earlier I said that there'd be
some features that it enables.
So let's talk about some of those.
If you target API level 11 or greater, you
actually get some nice benefits.
It enables the Holo theme for example, in
your app.
So that your, all of your UI controls look
modern, look up to date.
They don't look like they're Gingerbread versions.
So for those apps that you've seen occasionally
running on your Ice Cream Sandwich devices
that seem to have Gingerbread looking buttons,
it's because they haven't specified a target
SDK version of 11 or higher.
So it's really important that you do go and
you enable it.
So you get the Holo theme, then there's a
screen compatibility mode which is all about
saying whether you want app to stretch to
fit or zoom to fit.
And the more interesting one now is obviously
the legacy menu button.
So with our current generation of devices
like the Galaxy Nexus or in fact most of the
Android tablets, they don't have a physical
menu button.
If you try to run a legacy app, an older app,
on these newer devices what you'll find is
that in your navigation bar you get a little
menu button, it looks like the overflow button
but it's the menu button.
That's the legacy menu button and it's something
that really, you should be moving away from
and moving towards using the action bar.
So, target SDK version is what you use as
soon as you specify 11 or greater.
It'll enable these things on a newer versions
of the platform.
If you target 14 or higher, you automatically
get hardware acceleration, unless you explicitly
mention that you don’t want hardware acceleration
in your app.
But there are very few scenarios that we found
where you wouldn't want that hardware acceleration.
So really, you know, try to follow these best
practices of keeping the target SDK version
up to the maximum version.
Now, you might be asking yourself "Well, if
this is how it works, why doesn't it implicitly
target the newest version all the time?"
The reason is because there can be changes
in behavior and so when you make certain changes
in behavior to the Android framework, we make
sure that we keep the existing behavior if
the app is targeting older API levels.
So an example of changes in behavior is that
we changed the AsyncTask threading model in
API 13.
Where instead of having a pool of threads
that execute AsyncTasks you use a single thread
that runs AsyncTasks serially, but still in
a separate thread.
So there can be minor changes in behavior
and so that's why we recommend that you do,
not only do you update to the latest API level
in your target SDK version, but you do go
through your full test cycle.
>>Tony Chan: Yeah.
>> Ankur Kotwal: But as I said, the benefits
are great.
>>Tony Chan: Yeah, one thing I want to add
is also, like also for example the action
bar for when you enable set target SDK to
greater than 11.
So action bar will be something, will be enabled
at that point.
So if your apps hasn't been tested on the
latest version, so make sure you test your
app as well because that will have an impact
on the UI of the application.
>> Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, thanks Tony.
So the last one is the max SDK version and
actually as of Android 2.0.1, the operating
system doesn't even look at the max SDK version.
It's only used in Google Play.
So what happens is, if you specify max SDK
version, it means that Google Play won't often,
devices that are running newer versions of
the API, it won't offer your app, this particular
app to those devices.
So you’re kind of saying hey it'll only
run up to Ice Cream Sandwich and not any further
than that.
And really as Android app developer, what
you want to be doing is maximizing the number
of people, well maximizing the number of people
that can install your app, right?
So you don't wanna be specifying these max
SDK versions because remember what I said,
when you're using target SDK version and you're
fixing it to a particular value, we will ensure
that you get the same behavior.
So that AsyncTask change that I mentioned
before, if you're target SDK version isn't
13 or greater you will get the older behavior.
So in general we don't actually recommend
you use max SDK version and the only real
situation that we've, that I can come up with
where you might want to use it is if you're
using multi APK support, so in Play you're
kind of saying well I've got different APKs
targeting different versions of the platform.
So an example of where you might want to do
that is where you have an app today that’s
supporting a set of older Android versions
but in your next version of that app you kinda
wanna say "I'm no longer supporting those
old devices or old API versions, but I don’t
wanna take that old version off the store
for people that have old devices".
So then what will happen by using this, you
would specify max SDK version for your older
version of the app and then people with older
versions of the API, so you'd use a combination
of max and min obviously.
People with the older version of the platform
will get the older app so people on 1.5 1.6
and then your newer users can get the latest
updates and the latest features.
So it's really about making your life easier.
But it is something that developers can overlook
from time to time and we really recommend
that you certainly use minimum and target
SDK versions.
>>Tony Chan: Yeah, I think another thing I
want to add is another use case that I saw
the developer using the max SDK version is
when there is a major release, a Android OS
release, some developer may just temporarily
set the max SDK while they are doing extensive
testing on the major release.
I think that probably another real use case
that may be useful for temporarily setting
the max SDK to the [unintelligible].
[feedback noise]
>> Ankur Kotwal: Yeah.
Alright.
So that's user SDK.
The next one we'd like to talk about is uses
feature.
So you know often you may have an app that
you're using some sort of hardware feature
but it's not critical to the operation of
your app.
So an example of that is that you may have
a brilliant app that does great photo editing.
Now, one of the features of your app might
be that you use, that you allow the use to
take photos as well as edit existing photos
in the gallery.
Now, if you're taking photos you might be
wanting to use features like auto focus.
So you don’t want to get into a situation
where people that have devices that don’t
have a specific feature aren't able to use
the core functionality of your app.
So there are ways that you can actually specify
that "Hey I would like to use this hardware
feature if it's there, but if it's not then
go ahead anyway".
And that’s what we're gonna talk about now.
So in terms of how you would do this, you
would typically say "Hey, I wanna use a camera"
and then you can make decisions on which of
those features are optional.
So in the example here we're saying we're
using the camera we're also using auto focus
but you'll notice at the bottom of that white
text it says "Android required equals false"
And that's stating that this particular auto
focus feature is optional.
Now, keep in mind that when you request these
users features for anything that is said to
be required equals true, Google Play will
filter on those.
So at the top there we said uses-feature camera,
but we didn't actually specify required.
It's implicitly implied there that required
is true, that's the default value.
So the second part, the other focus is actually
saying it's optional.
So you can make a decision as which part of,
which of these features are optional in your
app.
And then at runtime what you do is that you
can go through the package manager to go and
find out if the system has that particular
feature.
So here we're checking if we have the feature
at runtime and then conditionally we are executing
our code.
So, this is a nice way to kind of, you know,
broaden the number of users, the number of
devices that your app can run on.
Whilst making sure, you know, your app still
hangs together.
Now I've provided a URL there at the bottom.
We actually had a blog post about this and
I'll just bring that up.
We had a blog post about this in, all the
way back in October actually, in October 2010
rather, I should add.
So it's worth your while to have a look at
this code and have a look through this blog
post that kinda walks you through it in more
detail.
[chime]
>> Ankur Kotwal: So let's go to the next section
of the presentation.
Uses-permission.
So obviously developers know you can, at install
time you specify which Android permissions
you'd like.
Well, what we've found is, that there are
a number of apps that request permissions
that are over and above what they really require
and users are starting to really object to
this.
Android users are quite tech savvy and they
tend to know, when, you know, an app is requesting
more than they need to.
Like a wallpaper app should never need to,
you know, read through my contacts, for example.
So what we wanted to do is present to you
a list of what we consider to be the worst
permissions that apps request.
There are circumstances where you might need
some of these permissions but you really need
to think long and hard.
So the first one, well, we're gonna start
from 10 and go backwards.
So changing Wi-Fi settings, there are very
few instances where you should need to change
a user's Wi-Fi settings.
Doing things on boot, you know, again it's
one of those things that, on boot you don’t
want a whole of bunch of apps starting to
do a lot of things, so keep that in mind.
You know, start your app at the right time.
Don’t put an unnecessary load on the app,
on the device by having your app start up
at boot and you know, and stay resident continuously.
You don’t need to know what other tasks
are running on a device in most situations.
There are again very few scenarios where you
would need to know this.
Obtaining a fine location, there are some
apps that actually do need a very specific
location but often that you'll find that the
course location will be good enough or the
network location.
You can also register for location updates
that other apps request.
So try and be smarter about retrieving this
location.
Getting fine location obviously also triggers
the GPS and you know, the GPS in these mobile
devices do consume a lot of power so really,
challenge yourself to, or ask yourself do
you really need it?
You should never need to read the system log.
And it's something in Jelly Bean that's actually
going away.
You'll be able to read your own logs but you
won't have, you know, this permission will
pretty much not do anything from Jelly Bean
onwards.
You certainly won't be able to see the log
of the rest of the system.
So number 5, you should never need to directly
call phone numbers.
We actually have an intent that you can fire
to say 'hey, go fire up the dialer and prepopulate
it with this phone number'.
The user still has to click dial and that's
the right way to do it.
Rather than directly call a number a yourself
through your app, fire up your intent.
The intent doesn't even require you to have
a permission to do it.
As I mentioned with things like wallpaper
apps asking for, reading contacts and calendar,
people are very conscious about their privacy
these days.
So, you know, again, ask yourself do you really
need that capability?
The same goes with bookmarks, displaying system
level alerts, you know, spamming the notification
bar, for example, and you know, in general,
system level alert permissions.
And number one, and this is the worst one,
is for apps to be sending and receiving SMSs.
There are some premium services that may do
this but the majority of the apps that we
see that are requesting these kinds of permissions
certainly don’t need to do it.
I'm not saying that they all have a malicious
intent, but you should really be careful about
this one because you will notice many of the
apps that request these sorts of permission,
get very negative feedback in the Play store.
And once it's there, you can't get rid of
that negative feedback.
So what should you do if you need some of
these permissions?
Firstly, describe the reason that you would
need the permission on the Play store.
You have a great big section of description
and in there, you know, you should state "Hey,
we need this permission because this is how
we are using it".
That's the responsible thing to do.
Users love transparency, so the more transparent
you are with them, the more they're going
to trust you as well to do the right thing.
You know there can be ways of architecting
your apps such that you can separate that
bit of functionality and make it optional
and though maybe like a plugin or add-on for
your app that users can install separately.
And then you can try triggering it through
that mechanism.
And finally, just put yourself in the shoes
of the user.
Would you be comfortable giving other apps
the permissions that your app is requesting?
If you truly believe that the answer is yes,
then go ahead and do some of these things.
But make sure again, transparency and you
want to gain the trust of the user and you
certainly don’t want to abuse it.
OK, so, that concludes the sort of short presentation
that we've had on the Android Manifest pro-tips,
for now what we're gonna do is move to the
Q&A section.
And of course this is gonna be questions related
to Android development.
You know we have the moderator questions,
we also have some people that are here live
with us.
So let's open it up for questions.
Let's see if the live audience has anything.
Hey, Andrew.
>>Andrew Kelly: Hey, just a quick one on the
stuff you were talking about just a moment
ago with permissions.
Is it likely that or an alternative that you'd
be able to have required kind of true or false
on permissions in the same way that you can
with features?
So, you know, if I could have location, fine
location as a permission, it's not actually
required and I could then test for that in
my app to say "OK, these five features of
my app can be used quite happily, but if I've
been given permission to query the location
and this extra feature, you know, like pinpointing
your location on map will then become usable?"
I mean at the moment a user has to accept
all of the permissions in one fell swoop rather
than individually choosing which ones I've
got access to which I could then query later
on.
>> Ankur Kotwal: Sure, that's a good question,
and so, let me start off by saying it's very
hard for us to comment on what direction we
are going but, let's just talk through some
of that.
Part of it is that we want to ensure users
have, have a really good experience when they
install apps, they're not presented with,
you know, a ton of questions, that say, you
know, here's four permissions that are requesting,
which ones do you want to turn on and off?
So we really need to think about the user
experience when it comes to installing apps,
and then we also need to think about well,
what about developers that have already got
an existing set of apps, that are not stating
those permissions are optional.
Should users be able to turn off permissions
on an app?
So what does it mean for our existing set
of apps, what does it mean for the user experience
if we were to do this?
So there are a couple of things at play here,
and so as I said, I can't really comment one
what's going to happen in the future.
But, uh yea.
>>Tony Chan: I guess one of the current implementation
developer currently is doing is to build some
plugins right, and in those plugin asking
for those optional permissions.
I mean if you have something that you think
your apps can be optional, you can pull those
features into a separated plugin so, and–
>>Andrew Kelly: When you say a plugin you
mean a separate APK file that's going to be
hosted on the Google Play store?
>> Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, so it's a separate
app, totally separate app and what you would
do, is you could go and check if that’s
installed and if it's not installed you could
say so when user tries to use a feature you
could say hey, you actually need to grab this
piece of functionality from the Play store
and you could direct them to the Play store,
you know page.
So they don't need to search for it or anything.
>>Tony Chan: And policy wise that's OK because
it's really offering different functionality,
it's not like you're putting like multiple
same application on the Play store, which
is what we discourage.
>>Andrew Kelly: Yeah, going back to Ankur's
bit just a moment ago, all you've done there
is changed the "hey, can I use your permission"
dialogue into a "hey, please go to the Google
Play store and download the map plug in for
your application".
You've not kinda made it a seamless-
>> Ankur Kotwal: hmm
>> Andrew Kelly:- there's still a user interaction
there.
>> Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, it is a delicate balance,
there's no doubt it.
It's not a simple problem, we certainly admit
that.
Yeah.
>> Andrew Kelly: Yeah, OK.
>> Ankur Kotwal: Alright, so we've got a couple
of other of people on the hangout.
Any other questions from anyone?
Before we move to moderator.
[pause]
>> Ankur Kotwal: OK, so let's move to the
moderator link, let me just bring that up.
And I will screen share.
[pause] [tapping noises]
Actually I'll just do that window because
then it will be nice and, nice and large.
There we are.
So Tony do want to walk us through these?
Or Anirudh?
[pause]
>>Anirudh Dewani: uhh
>>Tony Chan: Yeah, Anirudh, you want to take
or I can.
>>Anirudh Dewani: Uhh, I'm sorry which question
are we talking about?
>>Tony Chan: OK, I'll take this one.
So, "Why do developer, Android developer guides
for parsing XML recommend using an XmlPullParser
when it appears the SAX parsers are an order
of magnitude faster?"
So, I think one reason we are recommending
the Pull Parser, actually the SAX parser in
general is, performance wise compared to like
pull parser is really better and in most cases
like the pull parser performance is actually
better but from the article you post there,
the pull parser is, the SAX parser, there
are two implementation, the SAX one is really,
have a better performance.
But again, that actually depends on the benchmark
and we can take this as a feedback and bring
this back to the engineering team and see
whether there is really a performance optimization
there we can do on the pull parser.
Also, in terms of coding style, I think the
pull parser is better because you can select
event, you want to listen to versus the SAX
parser you have to, it's kind of a push model
instead of a pull model.
So, that's what I have anyway.
Anirudh you have anything to add or Ankur?
>>Anirudh Dewani: Yeah, I mean with the, the
one difference is with the pull parser, when
you need to do the event types they'll start
and you can only look at the events that you
are interested in but with the SAX parser,
you have to go through all the other ones
that come through the code that you write
so that's one benefit of using a pull parser.
>> Ankur Kotwal: OK, thank you.
So the next question is actually from Andrew.
Andrews says "I'm using a html image map for
each area that is clicked a blue rectangle,
it can be orange depending on device, it's
displayed briefly, even if the shape happens
to be a circle.
Can this be turned off?"
And he's tried a few web kit tricks in his
CSS but didn't have much luck.
Now, Andrew, I actually had a look at this
and it seems like the implementation that
we have in the, in web view unfortunately
has this side effect.
There is nothing we do at the moment unfortunately,
we can pass it on to the engineering team.
One thing I can tell you however, which it
doesn’t really help you, I think, if this
is an app it doesn't help you, but if it's
just a website-
>>Andrew Kelly: Yeah, it's an app.
>>Ankur Kotwal: - Ahh, it's an app, OK.
If it was a website, what I did was I tried
it in Chrome on Android and it didn't result
in the blue squares.
>>Andrew Kelly: Yeah.
Yeah, It's not in Chrome, yeah.
>>Ankur Kotwal: So, yeah.
So I think this is a difference in behavior
on the web view component on Android.
I even confirmed it actually in the browser
itself.
Not just the web view component.
So yeah, we’ll take that back and report
it to the team.
But is it a major show stopper for you?
>>Andrew Kelly: No it's not it's just something
the client I'm working with has noticed every
time that they use the image map and they're
kicking around on the page they see these
little blue squares appearing and it's just
a little bit annoying compared to when you
use these sites on the desktop or on an iPad
and you don't see the kind of highlighted
areas as you're kicking around on the site.
So it was just something I was trying to work
out if there was a bit of CSS that I could
stick in there or whether there was an attribute
in the XML I could put around the web view
that would turn that stuff of.
But yeah, I've tried several things and none
of them seem to work, so.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, sorry about that.
>>Andrew Kelly: It's alright.
>>Ankur Kotwal: We'll take it back to the
team-
>>Andrew Kelly: Good.
>>Ankur Kotwal: -and let you know.
Alright, next question; "Why is there no satellite
mode for MapView?
The method set Satellite actually sets hybrid
mode including both tiles of aerial imagery
with roads and names superimposed.
So right now there is no way to show only
aerial imagery without roads."
Anirudh?
>>Anirudh Dewani: Yeah, this is when we have
an open issue on our Android issue tracker
regarding this, this is something we'll look
at.
Thanks for your feedback.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Yeah, alright.
Again, thanks for reporting it, sorry that
we don’t actually have a work around for
you.
The only work around which I probably wouldn’t
recommend when it comes to using the map side
of it is, you know, using the web version
of the map.
And the only reason I say I wouldn't recommend
it is just because I find that using that
Java script version of maps in a web view,
it doesn’t perform as well as the native
map view, or sorry map activity.
So, yeah.
Next.
"Why are we not able to attach image in the
mail body?"
This person, this doesn't sound like a developer
question actually, so don't know the answer.
[chuckle]
Here's another one that doesn't sound like
a developer question: "Why does Android not
have an official Google sites app, I would
love to customize my websites on the go" I
suspect you could probably just go to the
Google sites page in your Android web browser
and modify it there.
I don’t know that there would be a massive
market for people changing their, modifying
their Google sites through a mobile app anyway.
That's not necessarily the official reason,
but that's just my thoughts.
So, not a developer question, we'll move on.
"Last time you had mentioned that there are
some new Notification support in the support
library, can you tell us what Notification
features have been added there?
Can Android 4.1-like notifications work in
earlier versions?"
Anirudh?
>>Anirudh Dewani: Yes, we've added rich notification
support and there are some release notes with
the support library which you can look at
what the features are.
But we do provide now rich notification support
like the Jelly Bean and ICS.
>>Tony Chan: Yeah, all the big content expanded
layout and priority, those things are now
supported in the compact, notification compact
library.
>>Ankur Kotwal: Cool, alright, well, there
are no more questions on the moderator, are
there any other questions from people that
are on the Hangout?
[pause]
Doesn't look like it.
Well, in that case well thank you for joining
us for our first episode for Android Developer
Lab Plus, we'll be back again next week.
As you noticed today we did a presentation
on the Android Manifest File, we'll be doing
more of these sort of topics of the week,
so we've got a few ideas in mind.
But if there are some specific topics that
you guys would like us to talk about please
let us know.
We are always interested in your feedback
and we do take that seriously.
So on that note, thanks for joining in and
see you next time.
>>Andrew Kelly: See you next week.
>>Tony Chan: Thank you, bye.
>>Anirudh Dewani: Bye